with 700 hours invested in the first
OverWatch what I longed for from
OverWatch 2 was a lot of meaningful
changes that pushed the series forward
while also remaining faithful to the
identity at first forged the identity
which made me someone not typically
interested in games driven solely by
their multiplayer elements such a big
fan of the first OverWatch and in some
ways OverWatch 2 delivers this offering
up new characters that feel at home
among the rest of the season roster
making the jump to 5v5 which is
brilliant and adding an enthralling push
mode
even better the game does all this while
retaining the same compelling back and
forth flow of battle and core gameplay
that fans love however these are tweaks
and additions in a game that otherwise
feels very familiar and that sameness
can sometimes make this new OverWatch
feel more like an update than something
brand new in the way that the two
suggests beyond that however OverWatch 2
often feels detached from the principles
and charm of the original one of the
greatest changes to OverWatch 2 comes in
the shape of its new 5v5 combat while
OverWatch featured six Heroes on each
team generally two damage to support and
two tanks OverWatch 2 eliminates one of
these tanks shrinking each team by one
and subsequently altering the dynamic of
battles little side scraps are nowhere
near as common as with only one tank
soaking up damage it becomes vital that
the whole team is there to support them
as well as provide enough of an attack
to break through the other team's
defenses it makes for faster and more
concentrated matches where cooperation
and coordination are crucial in your
every action or inaction feels a lot
more impactful it also means team
composition and understanding how
certain Heroes complement one another
matters far more than ever before this
is as intense as it sounds but the chaos
and Split Second strategizing also make
it incredibly fun with every secured
Victory a meaningful Triumph adding to
OverWatch 2's focus on creating engaging
intense matches is its newest mode push
in push each team is tasked with
reaching the middle of the map where a
robot in two barriers one on either side
await when a team has secured the robot
it begins to push the opposing team's
barrier whichever team covers the most
ground at the end of the match is then
crowned the winner in every game I
played the push and pull of battle was
incredibly tense feeling like a constant
series of tug of war where the tide
could change at any moment playing a
game of OverWatch has never felt quite
as good as it does in OverWatch 2. with
all its intensity it makes sense that
blizzard is going to extreme lengths to
prevents cheating and eliminate toxicity
within the OverWatch Community this
includes things such as requiring
players to register a phone number with
their Battlenet account as well as
eliminating one of overwatch's prized
features Metals these are no longer
doled out at the end of each game and
instead you only see the coveted play of
the game reel followed up by your
individual experience bar filling up
however you can see how your stats stack
up against your teammates and enemies at
any time with the touch of a button
making the elimination of metals seem
pointless for me the satisfaction of
earning medals during a match was a huge
incentive as they made me want to grow
as a player and help me identify when
certain teammates or opponents were
showing off some serious skills which
also contributed to how I gave out
commendations it's a subtle Omission but
one that I certainly felt however it's
hardly the most significant change to
overwatch's reward systems with
OverWatch 2's pivot to free to play also
comes with the introduction of a very
divisive feature in gaming the battle
pass
instead of randomized loot boxes
OverWatch 2 will offer players cosmetic
upgrades through its battle passes which
lasts an entire Nine week-long Season
these battle passes come in free and
premium versions but the premium pass
costing 1 000 OverWatch coins or 10 US
dollars as part of my review code
blizzard provided me with an OverWatch
2's first premium battle pass and at
this stage I've yet to decide how I feel
about it while I stand by the belief
that randomized loot boxes can be
predatory preying upon people's
willingness to essentially gamble for
whatever prizes they want it's harder
for me to decide just how consumer
friendly these particular battle passes
feel blizzard tries to curtail the
notion that buying the premium battle
pass is essential by touting that all
new Heroes which are scheduled to
release every other season will always
be available for free however everyone
who does pay for the premium battle pass
will get these Heroes instantly while
those who don't will have to level up
their battle pass to tier 55 to unlock
them in my time playing the game the
battle pass didn't level up all that
quickly despite me perform forming
decently in most matches and even
knocking out some of the Game's new
challenges this means players are in for
a long wait if they don't buy the
premium pass and will need to invest a
lot of time into unlocking levels which
feels unfair even with blizzard opting
to keep new characters out of
competitive PVP play for the first few
weeks sure much like in fortnite it's
possible to earn currency through the
battle pass that reduces the cost of a
current premium upgrade which could be
the smartest way to go about it if
you're planning on doing a whole lot of
playing but parts of this feel so at
odds with the spirit of the original
OverWatch which prided itself on not
placing Heroes behind paywalls and
keeping Playing Fields level similarly
for those jumping into OverWatch 2
without having owned the original
OverWatch it has now been revealed that
you'll have to play through a hundred
matches before you're able to use the
entire roster of characters a choice I
find completely bizarre even if I do
understand the intentions behind it the
team calls this decision part of the
game's first time user experience which
is meant to slowly onboard and acclimate
new players to the game however the idea
that players need to log in 10 to 20
hours improve themselves in order to
unlock other Heroes feels unnecessary
and a bit insulting this is once again a
thing that doesn't feel in the spirit of
OverWatch which encourage players to
explore and experiment freely to find
what they feel worked best for them that
ethos feels disingenuous now considering
a chunk of the roster is locked away the
lack of PVE at launch is a notable
Omission considering this aspect of the
game was meant to be the groundbreaking
Monumental feature that set it apart
from its predecessor it's not merely
disappointing to have to wait until next
year to see it it makes the sequel feel
more like an update simply packaged as a
whole new chapter additionally launching
the game with PVE would have added some
much needed heart and identity to the
game that despite how good it is to play
feels like an exercise in making
OverWatch fall in line with the modern
business models for multiplayer shooters
sure that might come off as a cynical
assessment but it feels just as cynical
as it sounds from doing away with
Winston's inspiring open speech which
very much speaks to the heart and soul
of what OverWatch represents to the
Sleek almost overly polished new style
of the game's menu to going free to play
and implementing a battle pass OverWatch
2 takes the franchise from a genre
defining shooter to a trend chasing one
as such it has begun to feel less like a
unique sci-fi superhero comic book in
video game form and more like well a lot
of other games that's not necessarily a
bad thing as many of those other games
are superb in their own right and
OverWatch 2's gameplay certainly lets it
hang the cream of the crop but it comes
at the cost of overwatch's unique
aesthetic and fascinating World which
felt diminished fortunately OverWatch 2
has a major silver lining in its
characters the subtle changes that older
characters have undergone both
cosmetically and in terms of their
abilities feel beneficial and succeed in
giving them that gentle refresh they
needed without disturbing the the magic
of their original designs although it
might take some getting used to not
having some key abilities the push
towards making tanks better at dealing
damage makes them a blast and adds to
the more aggressive nature of OverWatch
too similarly the characters like Sombra
and Cassidy now hit harder while Heroes
with stuns and freeze attacks no longer
bring games to a grinding Halt and
instead have abilities that keep the
game going and damage numbers going up I
cannot sing enough Praises for each of
the three new Heroes all of which are
excellently designed and extremely
versatile sojourn is a tactical
one-woman Army while junker Queen's
enemy weakening abilities give that
tanky Powerhouse a supportive Edge
kiriko in particular feels like no other
support hero before her is not only can
she pass through walls in order to heal
teammates but she can also deal some
serious damage with her Kanai making her
a fantastic pick for folks who usually
play the DPS role but need to take on a
support role
[Music]
where it counts OverWatch 2 feels like a
fantastic update to a multiplayer game
with mechanics that enable thrilling
skirmishes between teams of Heroes
however as a separate entity and sequel
it stumbles changes to the core game
player steps in the right direction but
it is surrounded by new points of
friction where there previously were
none thankfully as a live service game
things will be added or altered once
blizzard has more player feedback so at
very least the studio has a strong
Foundation to build upon there is plenty
of good to be found in OverWatch 2 and
In the Heat of battle the intoxicating
multiplayer dynamics that fans love are
there to enjoy all over again but if the
first OverWatch taught me anything it's
to dream a bit bigger about what games
can be and there still is a lot more
dreaming to be done here
[Music]
foreign